good evening I'm dr. Charles de Bravo
I'm on the board of the New York Society
for ethical culture and on its behalf
I'd like to welcome you tonight to
tonight's presentation for those of you
who are here for the first time I'd like
to give you a few words about our
society ethical culture was founded over
125 years ago by dr. Felix Adler on the
premise that the great world religions
and philosophies might differ in their
Creed's
but were in basic agreement as to the
deed the living of a moral life ethical
cultures believe that a code of moral
conduct can be derived by reason it does
not require supernatural commandment we
are humorists humanists we are humorous
also but tonight we are humanists
replace our faith in the demonstrated
capacity of people to deal with their
own problems we believe in the Worth and
dignity of all the inhabitants of the
world and it's a world that we seek to
protect we try by our conduct to live
our lives so as to bring out the best in
others and as a consequence in ourselves
the New York Society for ethical culture
has put its ethics into action by being
instrumental in the founding of the ACLU
the Legal Aid Society the visiting nurse
as a service the NAACP and by founding
the ethical culture Fieldston schools
which include ethics education and
community service projects as part of
their curriculum at all levels we stand
for the separation of church and state
and for women's white right to choose we
oppose the death penalty an ethical
choice based on reason requires as much
knowledge of the truth as possible this
knowledge is best gained using the
principles of scientific inquiry the New
York society applauds miss Joan Mellon
for her search for the truth about the
Kennedy assassination well not
necessarily
endorsing all of her conclusions we are
happy to provide this forum for her to
prevent present her views to you Joan
Mellon is a professor of English and
creative writing at Temple University
she's the author of 17 books on subjects
ranging from film criticism fiction and
Latin American Studies to crime sports
and biography her biographies kay Boyle
author of herself and Hellman and
Hammond Hammett with the New York Times
notable books of the year she's a
frequent contributor to the Baltimore
Sun and has written as well for the New
York Times the Philadelphia Inquirer
the Los Angeles Times and other
publications her most recent book which
will be available for purchase and
signing later a farewell to justice Jim
Garrison's investigation JFK's
assassination and the case that should
have changed history is the subject of
tonight's discussion for over seven
years of research into this subject will
be obvious to you in just a few moments
she will be also happy after the
presentation has been made to respond to
your questions society members will be
available to pick up cars that have been
provided for that purpose and now
professor Mellon
thank thank you very much for coming the
last time I was in this room was for the
memorial service for Jan sandy Lucas who
was one of our most distinguished
writers the author of common ground of
that race and class in Boston and Tony
during the course of his distinguished
career had a considerable conflict with
one of the institutions that I'll be
talking about in a few moments the New
York Times so when I think of this when
I come into this room of course I think
of Tony my book is about the Kennedy
assassination it began as a biography of
Jim Garrison for those who don't
remember and who don't even remember
Oliver Stone's movie he was District
Attorney of Orleans Parish place that no
longer exists and he remains the only
part of public official ever to have
brought anyone before the bar of justice
for participation in the conspiracy to
murder President Kennedy garrison
assumed that role because he discovered
that the person framed for the crime a
low-level intelligence agent named Lee
Harvey Oswald resided in his
jurisdiction between April and September
of 1963 the biblical metaphor is
inevitable that great harlot city New
Orleans destroyed by flood with among
its many sins incubating the Kennedy
assassination as after his suspect Clay
Shaw was acquitted and Clay Shaw was the
man whom the new evidence reveals was a
CIA operative guilty of participating in
the implementation of the murder of
President Kennedy garrison was asked how
he could imagine how he imagined he
could convict someone of conspiracy in
the murder of President Kennedy in a
Louisiana State Court garrison said I
guess I thought I was living in the
country I was born in he wasn't and we
aren't I'd like to suggest that the
truth about the Kennedy assassination
far from being a matter of interest only
to historians and not even to most of
them will help us understand how we
arrived at a point where people as
respectable as New York attorney Martin
Garr
this are comparing the current US
government with the rise of fascism in
the mid 20th century it's my belief that
the present state of our political
culture is a direct result of the fact
that those responsible for the murder of
President Kennedy have never been
brought to justice
to sum up a farewell to justice suggests
that the clandestine service of the CIA
not only covered up the truth about the
Kennedy assassination that's easy to
demonstrate from the four million
documents now residing at the National
Archives but organize the event itself
that the CIA escaped without penalty
this extraordinary fact has been
integrated over these 42 years into the
body politic it has produced a political
culture where the unthinkable has become
accepted practice meaningful freedom of
the press has fallen into serious
jeopardy for a flagrant example of what
we have come to we might revisit the
scantily reported exchange on December
1st between notre-dame professor Doug
castle and John you a former deputy
assistant to attorney General John
Ashcroft a participant in the writing of
the Patriot Act and now a Berkeley law
professor the subject of the debate was
the illegal expansion of presidential
powers president professor Cassell asks
if the president deems that he's got to
torture somebody including by touch
crushing the testicles of the person's
child there is no law that can stop him
and you answer's no treaty Castle
follows up also no law by Congress that
is what you wrote in the August 2002
memo
and you replies I think it depends on
why the president thinks he needs to do
that do that if professor castles
hypothetical question seems melodramatic
we have Morton Garbus alarmed by the
twin expansion of presidential and
police powers writing in the New York
Observer quote this country is
approaching a dangerous turning point
and suggesting that the United States
today bears some similarities to Varma
or Germany where liberal democracy was
not able to contend with the fascist
onslaught in Miami a few weeks ago I was
struck by the omnipresence on the
streets and restaurants of police
officers from a ver
of law enforcement agencies famously
Benjamin Franklin replied to a question
of whether this new land should be a
monarchy or Republic with the line a
republic if you can keep it what begins
as surveillance moves to wiretapping
then COINTELPRO tricks and finally to
murder a diagram of what happened to dr.
Martin Luther King jr. and why the
illegal NSA surveillance is so alarming
we have not been aided in understanding
the meaning of the Kennedy assassination
by the continued public sign silence of
those closest to President Kennedy one
day I requested of one of Jim Garrison's
law school classmates Tulane School of
Law class of 1949 is one more Thomas
here tonight call me this morning and I
there he is
Wilmer hi I asked Wilmer to ask his
acquaintance Kennedy advisor Arthur
Schlesinger jr. whom he believed was
behind whom he believed was behind the
assassination of President Kennedy
professor Schlesinger observed quietly
we were at war with the national
security people that the CIA at its
highest levels exacted its revenge on
President Kennedy has been an open
secret since 1963
a Gallup poll on the 40th anniversary of
the Kennedy assassination in 2003 found
that twice as many people believe that
the CIA was implicated in the
assassination as there were who accepted
the official fiction that Oswald had
acted alone in 1963 people were already
worried about the CIA's extraordinary
use of its powers in the New York Times
author crock wrote in October 1963 that
if ever there would be a coup in the
United States that would quote come from
the CIA and not the Pentagon the CIA
crock wrote was a malignancy on the body
politic it is difficult to imagine such
words being printed in The Times today
so profoundly has our freedom of the
press eroded since the time of the
Kennedy assassination after the death of
President Kennedy ex-president harry s
truman under whose watch the CIA was
created in 1947 wrote on the front page
of The Washington Post
that the CIA had been running a shadow
government becoming operational Truman
declared that the CIA was in urgent need
of correction brazenly Allen Dulles at
one point even told a reporter Allen
Dulles of course was director of Central
Intelligence even told a reporter to
think of the CIA as quote the State
Department for unfriendly countries the
CIA's policy making also involved
interference in the electoral process in
France and Italy funneling money to
certain political parties in Italy it
was the Christian Democrats whom the CIA
funded in an effort to prevent a
coalition of socialists and communists
from taking power the assassination of
Prime Minister Aldo Moro was connected
to that CIA campaign at the time of the
assassination Charles de Gaulle remarked
that John F Kennedy whom he admired had
died as a result of an intra government
conflict a situation not uncommon in
many countries the documentation
available since the passage of the JFK
Act in 1992 overwhelmingly supports de
Gaulle's view the rubber stamping of the
warren report by the press in 1964 seems
to mark the moment when the mainstream
press became embedded in official
versions of events chases of that
process have surfaced in April 1967 the
CIA issued a memo available now at the
National Archives I wish the New York
Times would read it instructing friendly
reporters on how to reply to challenges
to the Warren Report recommendations
that have resurfaced in the past few
years and a renewed attack are in a
renewed set of attacks on Jim Garrison a
decade after his death so which should
come as no surprise that the New York
Times for a year covered up the National
Security Agency domestic surveillance of
citizens with rubber stamps search
warrants issued under of quote foreign
intelligence services act run by the
Pentagon or with no warrants at all only
when their own reporter was about to
publish a book detailing the evidence
did The Times run that story it should
be horrifying that the convention
congressional debate about the Patriot
Act has been not whether there should be
a government capability but how long it
should be extended ponder The Times
treatment of Jim Garrison and later of
Oliver Stone
who dared to make a film with Jim
Garrison as its central character when
Garrison's first book a heritage of
stone appeared in 1969 John Leonard gave
it a positive review in The Daily Times
in his final paragraph
Leonard recounted a few of Garrison's
challenges to the Warren Report
something stinks about this whole affair
Leonard writes why were Kennedy's neck
organs not examined at Bethesda for
evidence of a frontal shot why was his
body whisked away to Washington before
the legally required Texas inquest why
by the next edition
Leonard's final paragraph had vanished a
third of a column slid down the memory
hole one of the people Jim Garrison
liked to invoke often was George Orwell
and in fact when he he nicknamed one of
his investigators Winston Smith of
course most people didn't recognize
where the reference came from Leonard's
review now closed with these words
frankly I prefer to believe that the
Warren Commission did a poor job rather
than a dishonest one I like to think
that garrison invents monsters to
explain incompetence it was an
extraordinary example of management
censorship of a book review to this day
as I said The Times tolerates no factual
challenges to the Warren Report they
appeared to be the only people who still
believe that Lee Harvey Oswald was
responsible for the death of President
Kennedy I spoke in Clinton Louisiana
last month that the oldest working
courthouse in the United States the
judge who introduced me asked the
audience how many people believe that
Lee Harvey Oswald was guilty not a
single hand went up the audience knew
the Warren Report was nonsensical
because it was an east feliciana parish
and the little Hamlet's of Clinton and
Jackson that Oswald appeared in the
company of Clay Shaw and a CIA contract
pilot named David Ferrie played by Joe
Pesci in Oliver Stone's movie in the
late summer of 1963 three months before
the assassination in the audience were
actual witnesses including the barber
who cut Lee Harvey Oswald's hair that
the Warren Report could so flagrantly
lie and present itself as a homicide
investigation while doing virtually no
investigation at all neither Clay Shaw
nor David Ferrie were interviewed for
the Warren Commission inspiring Jim
Garrison's quip they didn't call anyone
who was involved
has resulted in other presidential
commissions taking similar liberties
with the truth I wrote an op-ed piece
comparing the deliberate ignoring of
crucial information by the 9/11
Commission with a similar failure to
investigate a key lead by the Warren
Commission it began with the information
released by lute a lieutenant colonel
and Army Intelligence
Tony Shaffer that the able danger
intelligence unit have identified
Mohamed Atta I'm sure people know about
this story by now and other accused
hijackers as part of the cell of
al-qaeda operating in the United States
at least a year before 9/11
Colonel Schaffer had wanted this
information to go immediately to the FBI
only for Defense Department lawyers to
forbid Abel danger from contacting the
bureau the New York Times buried this
extraordinary information two-thirds of
the way into the paper The Washington
Post ran a pentagon denial period
information has to get out and I think
we have to account for why some of the
of these things weren't looked at as
part of the overall report colonel
Schaffer said on NPR Schaffer then
revealed something else he had presented
the findings of the able danger team to
Philip Zelikow that same executive staff
director of the 9/11 Commission who has
defended the recent attacks on Jim
Garrison as a dupe of the KGB Zelikow
saw to it that the able danger
information never appeared in the 9/11
Commission report and went on to deny
that he was given the information he now
works on the staff of Condoleezza Rice
one might ask could Zelikow and company
have gotten away with denying the
reality of a cover-up of vital
information about 9/11 if we had
demanded the truth from the Warren
Commission
I sent my op-ed pay a piece to 34
newspapers only one would print it the
Keywest citizen what has all this to do
with the Kennedy assassination per se
I'm suggesting that demanding the truth
about the Kennedy assassination even at
this late date is a step toward
restoring our basic freedoms the
discourse needs to go even further than
pointing to who planned and who
implemented the crime was the CIA acting
alone on its own behalf
well
interests did the agency serve in 1963
because the CIA eviscerated by George W
Bush was a very different institution
from the agency that waged war against
President Kennedy the discussion of who
rules America must begin with President
Eisenhower's and I'll forgive me for
repeating this warning against a
military industrial and we need of
course to add national security complex
we must never let the weight of this
combination endanger our liberties or
democratic processes President
Eisenhower said Eisenhower cut the
military budget as soon as he took
office the CIA the research reveals
sabotage President Kennedy's effort to
achieve they taunt with the Soviets in
the final year of his presidency through
the downing of Francis Gary Powers u2
over flight into the Soviet Union
President Eisenhower had a good
definition of national security
he said national security meant that the
country was proceeding in peace and
without a deficit Jim Garrison often
asked during his investigation cui bono
who benefits a lawyer friend of mine
living near Langley Forks in Virginia
pointed out to me some interesting
connections the Texas schoolbook
depository from which some but not all
of the shots were fired on November 22nd
1963 was owned by one D H Byrd B Y or D
Byrd also founded and was the commander
of the southwest post of the Civil Air
Patrol which included Louisiana and the
troop led by David Ferrie among whose
cadets was Lee Harvey Oswald in November
1963 one of birds companies I think he
had 50 LTV a major defense contractor
was almost bankrupt defense contracts
flowing from the Vietnam War changed
that and by 8 1968 the stock had
increased geometrically in value
meanwhile we know that President Kennedy
opposed vehemently a protracted ground
war and that as soon as he was dead
Lyndon Johnson dispatched thousands of
troops to Vietnam among th Birds
associates was a man named Neil Malin a
scout the skullenbones classmate of
Prescott Bush Mallon headed a company
called dresser industries and it was
dresser which sent George HW Bush
his friends son west to Texas in 1949 it
was from Allen that the first president
Bush named one of his sons mal and Bill
Birds buyer I'd plant in Mexico ferrite
a product involved in oil drilling by
the way I got an email today talking
about the mexico holdings of two
companies Halliburton and Schlumberger
both of which figure in the story
dresser industries was bought by
Halliburton in 1998 and at that time the
Kellogg subsidiary of dresser became
part of Brown & Root Brown & Root itself
had been bought by Halliburton in 1962
the year before President Kennedy's
death it is less well known that Brown &
Root profited not only from the war in
Iraq but first from Vietnam having
recognized the role of Brown & Root and
discovering that George Brown was a CIA
asset as the CIA's own release documents
confirm Jim Garrison hoped to
investigate Brown's role was the CIA
acting on behalf of President
Eisenhower's military-industrial complex
as a matter for further research the
intelligence connections of the Bush's
date from before the very founding of
the CIA the agency's mandate was
outlined in 1946 by Robert De Lovett who
was a partner of Prescott Bush at Brown
Brothers Harriman not least as readers
of the Nation magazine know and many I
hope were here after the Kennedy
assassination the FBI was enlisted to
brief CIA asset George Bush and by the
way the first president Bush always
denied when he was appointed director of
Central Intelligence that he ever before
had a role in the CIA CIA was briefing
the George Bush and not a low-level man
in the agency by the same name as was at
first claimed on the reaction the topic
was the reaction of the Miami
anti-castro cube to the Kennedy
assassination to the general observation
that the CIA represented the interests
of the oil defense industries and the
Pentagon must be added another motive
for the involvement of the CIA in the
assassination almost from the moment
Kennedy took office a conflict raged
between the President and the CIA once
Kennedy refused to be blackmailed by the
CIA into a full-scale invasion of Cuba
at the time of the Bay of Pigs
de gaulle's intra government
administration war erupted the
clandestine service of the CIA pushed
for an invasion of Cuba President
Kennedy declined and went on to fire the
director of Central Intelligence Allen
Dulles who really in the Warren
Commission we all know that throughout
Kennedy's brief presidency the CIA
treated him as an enemy they withheld
information which included details about
the Soviet missiles in Cuba also
concealed from President Kennedy with
the CIA's continued assassinations and
attempted assassinations of foreign
leaders John F Kennedy in turn sought to
rein in the CIA and to limit the scope
of its activities including reducing the
powers of the Director of Central
Intelligence he intended to transfer the
overflight u2 program from the CIA to
the Strategic Air Command he intended to
cut the CIA budget he sent I discovered
Richard Goodwin down to No Name key to
ask the soldiers of fortune training
there to take over radio Swann the CIA
station on behalf of the president they
declined and one of the soldiers of
fortune
down there said to did name was Gerald
Patrick having said to me John F Kennedy
was the last president who thought he
could take power Kennedy threatened the
existence of the agency as they knew
themselves Richard Reeves and his very
honest biography of John F Kennedy
quotes the president repeating over and
over again I've got to do something
about those CIA bastards those CIA
bastards I'm going to get those bastards
if it's the last thing I ever do it was
the persistent refrain of the Kennedy
presidency the current president has
also had his conflicts with the CIA he
however has espoused the very policy
favored by the CIA under Kennedy the
relentless pursuit of Foreign Wars to
achieve his end that war in Iraq no
matter what lie he had to tell to
implement a George W Bush had to do what
Kennedy knew he had to do as well
eviscerate the CIA
so the disinformation was spread that
the CIA had fallen down on the job
in fact the CIA had reported accurately
about the situation in Iraq and this
before the Iraq war CIA noted that an
invasion of Iraq was likely to lead to
civil war the CIA reported that there
were no weapons of mass destruction and
there
rather than give up his war the
president undercut the CIA then Bush
attempted to subvert the CIA further by
claiming that the CIA had endorsed what
it had not but which fit his projected
policy he claimed that the CIA had told
him first that there were weapons of
mass destruction in Iraq then he said
CIA had been wrong
neither claim was true the outcome was
the subordination of the clandestine
services and of the agency itself so
that the CIA director no longer enjoys a
daily briefing with the President and is
subordinate to a new Director of
National Intelligence whom the president
can control we should not be surprised
that the National Security Agency
empowered only to spy on foreign agents
abroad is spying on us instead it
research into the Kennedy assassination
reveals that although the CIA was
supposedly created to deal with foreign
threats the CIA operated together with
the FBI and the cover-up of the Kennedy
assassination documents reveal that this
mutual cooperation dates from the moment
of the founding of the CIA in Louisiana
the sabotage of Garrison's investigation
was led by the CIA operating beyond its
mandate domestically let me return to
some details of what Jim Garrison
accomplished as garrison once quipped
about the supposedly own assassin Lee
Harvey Oswald in fact Oswald was
virtually never alone know moreover he
was not involved with anyone who was not
connected to the CIA
Oswald was an FBI informant garrison
learned from Louisiana representative
Hale Boggs a member of the Warren
Commission and garrison always said that
the person who turned him on to the
investigation of President Kennedy's
death was Senator Russell long and
people often criticize garrison of
talking to the press too much and in
fact garrison kept his secret until the
day of his death a person who involved
him in the Kennedy investigation was not
senator Russell long in fact I talked to
Senator Russell Long's family and
garrison always talked about a plane
ride that he took with Russell long and
within which they discussed the Kennedy
assassination and Russell long convinced
him to investigate well what Russell
Long's family told me was that when
Russell long got off the airplane he
said garrison chewed his ear off about
the Kennedy assassination so the the
truth was the reverse and one of those
sodas are fortunate whom I just
mentioned told me in Miami the one true
thing you said was that nothing is as it
seems
it was Hale Boggs obviously Hale Boggs a
member of the Warren Commission who had
been at secret meetings closed sessions
of the Warren Commission which talked
about Lee Harvey Oswald's status as an
FBI informant now Allen Dulles told them
don't tell anyone about this and Hale
bonds of course told Jim Garrison and
that was what really persuaded him to
begin I discovered a conversation
garrison did not know about at the first
District Police Station where Oswald was
taken after he was arrested for a
disturbance when he was handing out his
pro-castro leaflets and by the way the
documents reveal that the fair play for
Cuba which Oswald supposedly represented
was heavily infiltrated by CIA those
documents are all available at the
archives
Oswald requested of lieutenant Francis
Martello of the New Orleans Police that
Martello called the FBI field office
call the FBI Oswald ordered Martello
imperiously tell them you have Lee
Oswald in custody
Oswald asked that special agent Warren
tube Ruiz come down to see him
obviously Oswald was someone the New
Orleans field office of the FBI knew
well the agent on duty that night John
Quigley then asked a young clerk named
William Walter the person who took Mort
loz called to check all the files locked
and unlocked for what they had on Oswald
on one file jacket in the locked filing
cabinet of the special agent in charge
where security files were kept were two
names
Lee Oswald and Warren des breweries to
this day mr. de breweries denies that he
ever knew Oswald and he's testified as
such to many committees so just before
my book came out I called him up on the
pretext of how to spell his name
correctly do you spell de with a capital
D or with a small D and I was waiting
would de bruit say anything after all
these years and what he said to me was
this after 40 years you wouldn't be very
you wouldn't be a very intelligent
person if you didn't change your mind
about things now that wouldn't hold up
as a confession in court but I take it
as one Oswald has also been part of the
C
a counterintelligence force defector
program Oswald I found new evidence to
show also work for US Customs in New
Orleans as many CIA people work for
customs and some of those CIA customs of
some of those customs officers or one of
them told the Church Committee
I've been waiting 10 years for someone
to ask me what happened and then he told
about Oswald's rollin with customs now
those boxes only 25% of the Church
Committee records are open to the public
so far so I had the summary of that but
not the actual deposition garrison began
by exploring Oswald's government
connections he indicted Clay Shaw for
participating in the conspiracy without
having our government records released
under the JFK a and by the way I want to
say again about the JFK act an
extraordinary development we're not
likely to witness anytime soon again and
these records show that Shaw was a CIA
operative and we have to thank Oliver
Stone because as a result of his film
people wrote to Congress and said if
this isn't true what does Oliver Stone
said in this film isn't true open the
records and at that moment in 1992 they
did wouldn't today by shepherding Oswald
around Louisiana Shaw was repaying the
CIA for considerable favors rendered
because Shaw was acquitted garrison
choses the title of his third book a
farewell to justice he never used that
title and so I appropriated it and I
think I had a right to do so I did a
book about Lillian Hellman once and
Lillian Hellman gave a course at Harvard
to creative writing students which he
titled stealing and she said it never
imitate it's not okay to imitate other
writers but stealing is perfectly okay
yeah you steal and you make it your own
and so I took Garrison's title you can
see that garrison was a literary man he
liked graham greene in particular he
loves Shakespeare and obviously
Hemingway part of my book includes how
federal agencies worked actively to
thwart Garrison's investigation garrison
was astonished that the FBI refused to
cooperate with New Orleans law
enforcement in an investigation of the
Kennedy assassination in fact J Edgar
Hoover we know that is subverted
garrisons effort witnesses came forward
to the FBI believing that in providing
the FBI what they're in for
they were simultaneously reaching the
district of a district attorney and the
document reads as follows
give garrison nothing Hoover wrote to
all special agents in charge adding in
reference to the special agent in charge
in New Orleans Robert Wright Meyer quote
tell Wright Meyer that I want him and
all personnel in New Orleans to keep
their mouth shut
this was February 1967 a week after Jim
Garrison's investigation became public
Bobby Kennedy's right-hand man Walter
Sheridan had spearheaded the blackmail
bribery and wiretapping that
accomplished the conviction of Jimmy
Hoffa the evidence of Walter Sheridan's
illegalities and the railroading of
Jimmy Hoffa is chronicled in Fred cooks
brilliant three-part series in the
Nation magazine a further irony is that
Chief Justice Earl Warren enlisted by
Lyndon Johnson to rubber-stamp the
preordained conclusion that Oswald
murdered President Kennedy wrote what
seems to me a brilliant dissent when the
US Supreme Court affirmed the Hoffa
conviction I asked a friend of mine that
saying is I asked Richard a Posner well
do you agree with me about Earl Warren's
dissent there and I have to tell you he
did not he did not Bobby Kennedy then
sent Sheridan to New Orleans as Sheridan
freely admitted to destroy Jim Garrison
that same National Security Agency
spying on American citizens today
spawned Walter Sheridan who was also
cleared for service with FBI and CIA
Sheridan personally telephoned the
governors of several states to ensure
that garrison subpoenaed witnesses not
be extradited back to the state of
Louisiana not a single witness was
returned to New Orleans in the recent
attacks on Jim Garrison maybe found
their preposterous notion that the only
reason garrison focused on the CIA was
that he was the victim of KGB propaganda
flowing from an Italian newspaper
'piease era this total falsehood and I
mentioned this earlier has been defended
by Philip Zelikow the executive director
of the 9/11 Commission one of the
half-dozen anti garrison articles
appeared not surprisingly on the CIA's
own website studies and intelligence as
a biographer among the questions I asked
was did Jim Garrison take bribes from
profiting from pinball machine gambling
than illegal in Orleans Parish
you could play pinball but you couldn't
gamble with a pinball machine for which
he was charged by the federal government
was Jim Garrison dishonest the new
documents reveal that after Shaw's
acquittal after he perjured himself
insubordinate re garrison was ready to
continue his investigation only for that
same operative Walter Sheridan to return
to New Orleans and blackmail Garrison's
friend and former chief investigator
Pershing surveys this is a dog this is
from the documents not from interviews I
did a thousand by now
well Gervaise not helped them to nail
garrison for taking bribes from pinball
gambling interests surveys would go to
jail for eight years the document is
that specific for income tax fraud so we
see in this story the mutual cooperation
of agencies the FBI helping the CIA the
IRS enlisted by the National Security
Agency and the CIA years later on the
occasion of Oliver Stone's film JFK
Anthony Lewis wrote in The New York
Times that garrison had taken bribes in
fact garrison was acquitted the bribes
were indeed going to a quote big man at
Tulane and broad but it was not six foot
6 inch Jim Garrison a chief of police
Joseph gia Rizzoli Police Headquarters
was also at Tulane and broad addressing
a frequent attempt to discredit Jim
Garrison I also had to ask was garrison
tied to the Mafia did he blame the CIA
for the assassination as a way of
protecting the Mafia
I learned that Carlos Marcella the mafia
chieftain of Louisiana and Texas
despised garrison and wanted him out of
office
garrison was quote unreliable Marcello
complained to governor John J McKeon
whose assistant John Tarver relayed this
to me
McKeon himself did take bribes and a
person who ran against him in 1968 a
name John or Eric told me the story
where John R Eric's campaign manager was
visited by Carlos Marcello's person and
offered $50,000 and John R Eric's men
refused and Carlos Marcello's
representative said well a big bid John
took his so in other words when someone
was giving $50,000 to each
the final chapter of my book entitled
rabbi reflects my interviews with a
person who was involved in setting up
the assassination a man named Thomas
Edward Beckham
it describes the CIA training at a
facility in Virginia Beckham presented
me with a government document which
describes him as a man who would feel no
guilt about killing this phrase matches
and language documents released by the
Church Committee describing the
assassins hired by the CIA in their
assassination attempts against foreign
leaders Lumumba Trujillo diem and of
course Fidel Castro Beckham had been
subjected to a polygraph by the New
Orleans police in the late 1970s when
Robert Blakey and Gary Cornwall who
headed the House Select Committee on
assassinations discovered this the
Louisiana investigators were suspended
for conducting a polygraph without
authorization
the CIA controlled that investigation as
it did the Warren Commission my favorite
anecdote concerns the moment when former
Justice Arthur Goldberg was asked to
head the committee after Philadelphia
prosecutor Richard a Sprague was fired
knowing that the CIA held the truth
about the assassination Goldberg
telephoned the director of Central
Intelligence Stansfield Turner and asked
whether should he take the job he would
be given full CIA cooperation he asked
his question again there was silence he
asked his question again only then did
Turner reply I thought my silence was my
answer Goldberg did not take the job my
final question came at my last interview
in Miami in June of 2005 it was one that
also perplexed Jim Garrison why did
Bobby Kennedy tried to sabotage his
investigation through Walter Sheridan
I interviewed a Cuban close to Robert
Kennedy who revealed that Robert Kennedy
had Oswald under surveillance in New
Orleans during the summer of 1963 like
Professor Schlesinger Robert Kennedy
looked first to the CIA for
responsibility in the murder of his
brother on the day of the assassination
Bobby confronted John McCone the
director of Central Intelligence with
this question did the CIA kill my
brother
he told Harry Ruiz Williams one of the
Cubans working for him confirming his
prior awareness
servoz wall one of your guys did it and
it was not a question but a statement
wanting to be certain Bobby sent that
same wall to Sheridan to Dallas to find
out if the Mafia had planned the crime
they had not Bobby also asked a mafia
connected Chicago lawyer Julius Dresden
who worked for the NLRB the same
question the answer is Dresden reported
to Walter Sheridan was that the
assassination was not a mafia hit years
later Sheridan would testify under oath
that the Mafia was behind the
assassination he knew better it was in
the circles of the anti-castro movement
that Bobby Kennedy moved his aim to
protect the life of his brother from
some Cubans still furious about the Bay
of Pigs his other aim was to quote
neutralize Fidel Castro since the church
committee hearings newspapers have
reported on operation Mongoose the CIA
mafia plots to assassinate Fidel Castro
Bobby Kennedy's separate efforts have
been less widely publicized but I
haven't confirmed from many people
including Ramsey Clark it was in this
Miami research that I discovered my
parallel between the cover-up by the
9/11 Commission of the able danger
information and a similar set of facts
that faced the Warren Commission in its
closing days it reveals information that
bears upon why Robert F Kennedy was so
nervous about Jim Garrison's
investigation and about any
investigation of his brother's death
this began at the Bethesda autopsy
nothing to do with Jim Garrison one of
the doctors Pierre Fink testified for
the defense in New Orleans at state of
Louisiana versus Clay Shaw that the
Kennedy family had asked that the
trajectory of the president's wounds not
be examined if my brother were killed
garrison said I would be interested in
getting the individuals involved no
matter who they were garrison made this
statement on national television
exasperated by the persistent questioned
by news people if you're on the right
track why isn't Bobby Kennedy helping
you late in its deliberations the Warren
Commission discovered that Lee Harvey
Oswald had visited a Cuban exile and
former law student named Sylvia
odyo in Dallas in late September 1963
during the weekend of the assassination
mrs. odio and her sister Annie both at
once identified Oswald is the
who would visited them in the presence
of two Cubans whom Sylvia Odia would
never identify mrs. Oda testified before
the Warren Commission she said that the
day after that visit one of the Cubans
had telephoned her and in the course of
the conversation remarked that Leon
Oswald had said President Kennedy should
have been assassinated after the Bay of
Pigs and some Cubans should have done
that it's so easy to do it indicating
both foreknowledge of the assassination
and that Oswald was being set up the
Warren Commission never adequately
investigated this information they
certainly didn't call Leopoldo the man
who phoned let Sylvia O do just as the
911 Commission didn't feel obliged to
investigate the able danger documents
the Warren Commission's chief counsel J
Lee Rankin expressed irritation at the
very suggestion that Sylvia O do stories
should be fully investigated
murmuring we were supposed to be closing
doors not opening them years later
Rankin was bitter that the FBI in CIA
had concealed vital information from the
Warren Commission deposed in the late
1970s by the House Select Committee on
assassinations Rankin admitted that he
regretted that he had taken the CIA's
word that Oswald was never a CIA agent
invited to ask if he had anything
further to say this was after the
questioning Rankin had a question for
the lawyers and committee members in the
room was the HSC a investigating whether
the people involved in the CIA cover-up
were involved in the assassination as
well he received the same response
Arthur Goldberg had silenced the Warren
Commission lacked a context in which to
evaluate the incident of Oz were
visiting Sylvia o dó because the FBI and
CIA both on the instruction of chief
chief of counterintelligence James
Angleton concealed the CIA's history of
attempts to assassinate Fidel Castro now
a matter of public record in my pursuit
of the question of why Bobby Kennedy
tried to sabotage Jim Garrison's
investigation garrison used the word
torpedo I studied the minutes of the
president's foreign intelligence
advisory board I recommend that to all
researchers and the Church Committee
papers I tried to interview Cubans who
work closely with the Attorney General
and this is some of what I discovered
I'll close Bobby Kennedy had assembled a
team of anti-castro Cubans one Manolo
rebozo was now living in Nicaragua
having married into the wealthy Somoza
family another man well Artie Mays did
but I did find a man named Angelo
Mercado a man so devoted to the Kennedys
that had at his citizenship hearing he
changed his name from her gato to
Kennedy in homage to a person whom he
admired that is Bobby if you look in the
on't find him in the Miami telephone
book Angelo told me that Bobby's
instructions to his special team were
twofold
one aim was to find a means of getting
rid of Fidel Castro Bobby's other aim
was to protect his brother he sent these
Cubans to New Orleans moving among as
Angelo puts it Castro's agents double
agents and Cubans working for the CIA
they hope to quote neutralize a future
assassin in New Orleans Angelo morgado
ran into Lee Harvey Oswald who was
moving among the anti-castro community
he put Oswald unto under surveillance
when I mentioned that I had discovered
Oswald as Oswald's acquaintance with an
anti-castro Cuban named Warren Valdez
and of course there he laughed that
couldn't possibly be anybody's real name
who worked at Clay Shaw as International
Trade Mart Angelo was dubious how could
that be he knew everyone Oswald was
acquainted with and he didn't know of
this man that's how close to Oswald they
drew scrutinizing Oswald and reporting
back to Bobby his team discovered that
Oswald was an informant for the FBI
learning this Bobby reasoned if the FBI
is controlling him he's no problem Bobby
underestimated the role Oswalt had been
induced to play in the murder of his
brother and ceased to make him a major
target of his concern Bobby knew quote
something was cooking in New Orleans
Angelo Mercado told me but Bobby urged
caution he was out of his depth in
September it was Angelo and a fellow
veteran of the Bay of Pigs who traveled
from New Orleans to Dallas to visit
Sylvia oh do angelo believed they were
there to marshal help for the
anti-castro efforts and talked about
buying arms to support anti-castro
efforts within Cuba
mrs. O Dios father in jail and Cuba
headed a liberal organization called
hooray
J ure its position Fidel he's missing
Fidel Angelo believed that he could
trust his companion referred to in the
Warren Report as Leopoldo because not
only was he a fellow veteran of the Bay
of Pigs
but his brother was running for mayor of
Miami he was respectable the next day
out of Angelo's hearing and that's very
important out of Angelo's hearing
Leopoldo phoned mrs. Odile
to tell her how Leon Oswald had talked
about the need to murder President
Kennedy Leon is kind of nuts Leopoldo
stated setting up Oswald as the Patsy
Oswald's mental imbalance forms the
conclusion of the Warren Report Oswald
was called Leon a number of times not
least at a gathering at David fairy's
apartment where Clay Shaw and ferry
Garrison's chief suspects discussed what
their alibis would be for November 22nd
at Sylvia adios Angelou used his true
given name Angela Morgado Leopoldo was
an alias placing Oswald in the company
of so close an associate of Bobby
Kennedy in an incident that points to
foreknowledge of the assassination as
well as the framing of Oswald created
the trap that would silence Bobby
forever Bobby asked his aide Frank
mankiewicz whether quote any of our
people were involved and mankiewicz told
me he had asked himself did you think
there might think Angelo meanwhile had
been betrayed by a companion he believed
he could trust a man not so much
assigned to the overthrow of Fidel
Castro as Angelo believed as he was to
arrange for Oswald to be blamed for the
murder of the president Leopoldo was a
Cuban named Bernardo de Torres a virtual
flood of documents reveals that he was
an asset of both the CIA and military
intelligence when he was subpoenaed
before the House Select Committee CIA
arrived on the day de Torres was deposed
to insist that he be granted immunity
the CIA so totally controlled that
committee that they agreed to the CIA
demand that de tourists would not be
questioned about the period of time
leading up to the Kennedy assassination
both the Warren Commission and the HSC a
buried what they knew about Oswald's
participation in anti-castro activities
information that would have led directly
to the role of the CIA in the assassin
I believe that we are now suffering the
consequences of allowing lies about what
happened to President Kennedy to remain
unchallenged the consequence of the
public not demanding that the murder of
the head of state be properly
investigated has led directly to the
current undermining of the integrity of
our democratic institutions not least
the press an obvious consequence of the
obfuscation z' of the Warren Commission
and the House Select Committee has been
the ease with which the 9/11 Commission
was able to conceal important truths I
wrote my book to make a small
contribution to the need for government
accountability and openness because what
is at stake if I can be grandiose for a
second is democracy itself and now I'll
close with a one-line it's a line from
dr. Martin Luther King jr. from a sermon
of 1967 the year before his death no lie
can live forever thank you
thank you very much Joan this is the
time for you to ask questions by means
of the white cause that you received and
our society members will pick them up
and bring them to me while we're waiting
obviously this assassination occurred
40-plus years ago and during this time
we have been subjected to books papers
by historians perhaps certainly
ballistics experts forensic experts
acoustics experts lawyers people who
claim to have been mistresses of various
protagonists in this situation how are
we able at this particular point so far
from the fact to establish truth from
fiction that's a very good question
Chuck and I think there is no answer to
it except that when you find a piece of
evidence it should connect with other
evidence that you have if it doesn't
connect with what you were reading
though you throw it out the hard work
still has to be done and I think there's
no easy road there's no way to wade
through all the disinformation with
which we've been hammered since for 42
years and I think that disinformation I
have to say is still going on at the
time that my book was published a book
came out reviving J edgar Hoover's view
approach that the Mafia killed President
Kennedy two days after my book is
published after all these years suddenly
that appears well it turns out that the
sources are denying that they said what
this book says they said meanwhile a
german documentary comes out maybe a
week ago saying really it was Fidel
Castro which was the original CIA view
before they decided no they'll blame
oswald acting alone the reason that
oswald was handing out pro-castro
leaflets on the streets of New Orleans
was preparation for the CIA ultimately
blaming Fidel Castro for the
assassination so I don't know what to
say to that except go to the National
Archives look at the documents
don't trust me or anyone else well my
book has all the notes citing every
document that I used roll up your
sleeves and look because I think it's
worth it I see do we have any questions
yet for me to ask if not let me ask you
another question about Lee Harvey Oswald
himself and his being a patsy so to
speak there was a time that he was asked
to establish his credentials as a pro
Cuban sympathizer and this was to
perhaps allow him one of several
different explanations to either
infiltrate Cuba or perhaps established
motivation for an assassination did he
know that he was being put into this
role at this particular point was he
just a dupe at that particular point or
at what point did he think that he was
perhaps not doing the work of the CIA in
perhaps bringing down the president I
think that [ __ ] didn't know what was
happening until he was arrested in
Dallas and then I think he wanted to
show his CIA handlers that he was still
with the program that they really ought
to rescue him because when Oswald did
when he was arrested in Dallas was to
ask for John apt to represent him and
John apt as we know was a lawyer who
represented the Communist Party
so here's Oswald signaling to his CI
handlers something has gone terribly
wrong I didn't do this and get me out of
it look I'm still with the program I'm
still maintaining my disguise my cover
which was that I was Pro Castro and
David at Lee Phillips a name familiar to
researchers of the Kennedy assassination
was the CIA propaganda specialist who
managed the CIA and filtration of fair
play for Cuba
thank you this question relates to can
you explain further why JFK stymied the
investigation
addressing to a great Kennedy Bobby
Bobby Kennedy yes RFK Bobby Kennedy is a
hero to many of us and this was
obviously sad information when we read
it can you give us some more insight
into that I want to say something in
defense of Bobby Kennedy and and that is
that he must really have posed a threat
to those who murdered his brother or he
himself would not have been assassinated
just as he was about to really run for
the presidency with a good chance of
winning there's no question that Bobby
Kennedy tried to stop not only as I said
Jim garrison but any investigation when
Jim Garrison went into federal court to
ask for the records of the autopsy the
x-rays and photographs the Kennedy
family said afford very hard and
defeated the Orleans jurisdiction and
they didn't get those materials I think
that Bobby Kennedy didn't want it to
come out that he was running his own
team that was attempting to quote
neutralize fidel castro i think it was
part of the times I think that the
Kennedys had contradictory policies John
McCone said it many Kennedy family
friends said it they were pursuing
contradictory policies which I suppose
many political leaders do and it's kind
of difficult for us to accept John F
Kennedy was attempting rapprochement
with Fidel Castro he sent an emissary
William Atwood to Cuban John Arthur
Schlesinger told me go read our Carlos
let sugars memoirs because Carlos let
you go was the Cuban ambassador to the
UN and they were making advances on
normalizing relations between the United
States and Cuba and yet at the same time
the Kennedys were involved in sabotaging
Fidel Castro I forgot now I forgot the
person is incredulous that this could be
but I think that the situation isn't so
easy to understand John if Kennedy is
the person after all who sent the Green
Berets Phoenix program and Special
Forces into Vietnam these was these were
death squads and tens of thousands of
Vietnamese died in the early 1960s under
these programs and as true John F
Kennedy did not want to send ground
troops into Vietnam but he was not the
Prince of Peace either
as some people have said and I think we
we shouldn't be afraid of the truth
wherever it leads okay I'll read this
question when garrison told the truth he
was attacked in the press when the movie
JFK came out all of a stone was attacked
in the press can you describe the
mechanism that makes these attacks
possible and has your book been attacked
in a similar fashion what can we do
about the corruption of the media by the
CIA and more recently by Bush can we
hope that the CIA will now try to bring
down Bush it's too late I think Bush
feared it because that's why he invited
the CIA and that's why they're the we
have a Director of National Intelligence
now and the CIA the people in the
clandestine service resign right and
left they the CIA is no longer the power
that it was so they the current
administration has accomplished that end
the CIA was someone to be feared not to
be trusted and the Bush administration
took no chances what can we do about it
standing here today I hope I'm doing
something about it writing the book I
hope I'm doing something it seems such a
small thing it seems it's a pity if I
really were doing something that was a
threat I would be shot and then I must
not be doing something right now people
who write books must not be doing enough
Jim Garrison himself survived because
they had other ways of discrediting him
we have I think that the New York Times
Book Review has lost the the influence
that it once had I think we have the
Internet
however I have to say that if you look
on amazon.com and you read the reviewer
the reviews by citizens you don't know
what to make of it I'm only thankful to
amazon.com for continuing to publish as
under my book the first review which is
by Eddie kacica and I don't know if he's
here tonight but he promised me he would
be and he wrote this review called Saint
Joan and all the reviews and all the
negative reviews keep coming keep coming
but somehow somebody at amazon.com is
keeping that Saint Joan review right on
the top so we do what we can
how could a conspiracy
that had to involve so many people he
kept so secret for over 40 years it has
not been secret I think people know
Richard Goodwin certainly knew what that
the soldiers of fortune down there who
were training to invade Cuba were
refusing the order of the executive of
the President of the United States I
would like we would only hope that the
people would the people who were
responsible for this crime did not come
forward even I think it was the New York
Times or The Washington Post titled the
obituary of Richard Helms he died with
his secrets I don't think that we're
going to bring the people to justice I
think what's important for history is to
understand what has happened in our
country in an effort to try to stop
what's happening now which is shocking
just shocking
the CIA agent in charge of the Bay of
Pigs fired by Kennedy and the mayor of
Dallas were brothers was that connection
used to facilitate the assassination if
so does that bolster the case for CIA
involvement well that was Jim Garrison's
contention whoever wrote that knows Jim
Garrison well Jim Garrison was
preoccupied all his life by the fact
well let me just go back a little bit
remember John F Kennedy fired Allen
Dulles who was the director of national
intelligence as sorry the CIA director
of I'm tired hurt dear intelligence and
his second-in-command I was the second
in command was General Charles Cabell
and when Dulles was fired General
Charles Cabell had to resign who should
be mayor of Dallas at the time of the
Kennedy assassination
but Earl Campbell brother of general
Charles Campbell
so garrison was really struck by this
and of course the parade route was
changed and for students of the Kennedy
assassination who know better than I do
the details of this it appears that the
mayor had something to do with the
changing of the parade would certainly
that parade route was outrageous going
then taking that slow ride you know
passing the Texas School Book Depository
and so garrison was persuaded that there
was definitely a connection and that
connection linked Dallas to the CIA
what percentage of Warren Commission
archival records are still sealed by the
federal government and is there any
mechanism for speeding there unsealing
that's interesting I don't know the
exact figure there I do know about the
church committee records where 75% is
sealed as I said I don't know what to
say about that people have constantly
begged Steve Tilley at the National
Archives to go forth and fight for this
and so far I don't think anything is
being done on this that I know of anyway
meanwhile however the CIA is continuing
to dump documents at the National
Archives and I have a friend who goes
three four times a year
nothing is catalogued nothing is filed
you don't know what it is but you wait
through the boxes and you can find some
very interesting materials and I think
that much is not there I have one story
and that is that Hunter Leake
Hunter Leake was the second-in-command
at the CIA field office in New Orleans
and he confided to a reporter in
Louisiana that right after the Kennedy
assassination he destroyed many Oswald
records that the CIA field office in New
Orleans had and other records he loaded
into a u-haul truck and we drove to
Langley and we haven't seen those
records I have another anecdote that
I'll tell you and that is at the Tulane
library the special collections of the
Tulane library held the papers of Hale
Boggs and the curator of those special
collections Bill Mantaray told me that
one day two FBI agents walked into the
Tulane library and said they had the
permission of Lindy Boggs and they
removed from the Hale Boggs papers all
references to the Warren Commission or
to the Kennedy assassination when I
heard about this I filed a Freedom of
Information suit to charge asking the
FBI for the records and we never got
anything from it gone what do you think
of McClellan's book that implicates LBJ
in the assassination I don't know what
to say about that I think that we'd have
to connect again Lyndon Johnson III I
think the only evidence in that book
that has any relevance is that handprint
on the carton in the tech
the School Book Depository and I think
the even the fingerprint experts have
questioned people here maybe know better
than I do
whether that handprint is the the
handprint of this man I think his name
is Wallace Charles Wallace and I'm sorry
and Jack bones Mac sorry Mac Wallace
thank you and is this really true now
the fact that there were many murders
involved as Lyndon Johnson came to power
nothing connected with the Kennedy
assassination but just many murders is
very interesting and I recommend that
the book not for what it says about the
Kennedy assassination but for the
discussion of the politics of Lyndon
Johnson and his ascent to the presidency
I would have liked to have heard more in
the book about Jack Ruby and what were
the connections between Jack Ruby and
Oswald prior to the assassination I know
you placed them together at various
times can you tell us a little bit more
about Jack will be as a person so much
to tell about Jack Ruby one of the just
about two days ago someone in Louisiana
who was working on Jim Garrison's
investigation sent me on Xerox of a
photograph of Jack Ruby as a young man
and he looks and he's with another young
man who seems to be in drag and I and if
many that we trust Cheramie who was one
of the witnesses in this case who was
murdered in 1965 often spoke and I have
this in my book of a sexual relationship
between Jack Ruby and Lee Harvey Oswald
and I don't know all about it but I'm
remind there's a lot to be said of that
Jack Ruby maybe that's it somebody in
fact Angela Morgado said to me here's
what your next project should be you
should write a book about Jack Ruby and
the same thing was said to me by one of
the Louisiana investigators for the
House Select Committee Jack Ruby what I
have in my book as Chuck says are many
examples which reveal that contrary to
what Jack Ruby said that he knew Lee
Harvey Oswald very well and in
particular my witness Thomas Edward
Beckham said to me that on the day of
the assassination he he talked to
someone and he said how could Jack do
that to Lee so the fact that these
people were very well acquainted sir
is important and needs to be in the
mainstream press just to get the
discussion going there's a lot to be
said Jim garrison said that Jack Ruby
and I hope I get it right this time Jack
Ruby was a member of the Mafia branch of
the CIA garrison by the way never denied
that the mafia was involved in the
assassination the issue was who planned
the crime and whose idea was it and who
was in control of it changing the
subject a little bit who do you think
might have planned the attempted murder
of general Walker and who attempted to
carry it out it's dubious whether it was
Oswald I don't know the answer to that
this is a somewhat esoteric but rather
learning question perhaps beyond me
written by a professor of history at
johns john jay find it in your research
did the name William Harvey come up in
any significant way also how did it go
with Doug Brinkley and can you talk
about CV Jackson how did it go with Doug
Brinkley must have found that on my
website right
well I Doug Brinkley the presidential
historian asked me to address his class
which is a class in the history of the
Cold War at Tulane now of course you
know that there was no class at Tulane
and it was quite shocking of course to
see what was left of New Orleans but
Tulane was not what was left William
Harvey was the CIA executioner he was
the person who created executive action
programs for the CIA which meant their
murder capability and the irony of that
is that at one point John F Kennedy
asked the CIA to create an executive
action capability and of course they had
already done so William Harvey is a very
interesting figure I had a lot of
trouble finding a publisher and finally
I found Potomac
books this little publisher in Dulles
Virginia when I first heard that it was
Dulles Virginia that all these people
are there into the hand of the CIA this
is impossible they're going to and the
friend of that same lawyer who lives
near Langley Forex said to me listen
they're gonna they'll buy your book then
they'll bury it and you'll never get
published and and this publisher I think
was very courageous in publishing a book
which said that the CIA killed President
Kennedy involved in it especially since
they mostly published memoirs of CIA
officers and at the moment they have
under contract what a biography of
William Harvey so that's what makes me
think of William William Harvey is a
figure in Robert littles wonderful novel
helped me there's this gentleman over
here that knows everything
what was what is the what is the title
of Robert Lee tells novel about the CIA
the company excellent thank you in
November 2004 I thought the picture of
William Harvey in there was a quite
exact though it's not literary fiction I
grant you that for literary fiction on
the subject of the Kennedy assassination
I don't think we could do with that Don
DeLillo he's my favorite author I tell
him there's no student of mine in this
room that hasn't read Don DeLillo and I
urge you to read Libre which is his
fictional version of Lee Harvey Oswald
in New Orleans written before the
release of any of the documents and also
underworld which describes the
conspiracies and government that an
edition of including the Kennedy
assassination in November 2004 the New
York Times printed a significant article
about the modern acoustical analysis of
the police belt to determine where the
three or four shots were fired do you
know any outcome of this acoustical
analysis well I'll tell you one thing
about the acoustic analysis the House
Select Committee on assassinations which
to which I referred in my talk
Robert Blakey the professor at Notre
Dame who's been the proponent of the
Mafia did it you've seen him on the
History Channel often he was warning
really according to Richard Billings who
the co-author of his book he wanted
really to rubber-stamp the Warren Report
and to blame Lee Harvey Oswald at the
last minute what comes
but that dick de belt and the dicta belt
shows that at least four shots were
fired at Daley Plaza making it
impossible for Oswald to have been the
lone assassin and it was only that dick
de belt which said that that there had
to be a conspiracy which was it seems so
open-and-shut now but at that time in
the late 1970s that was an important
step despite everything negative that
I've said about the House Select
Committee they did say that there was a
conspiracy and it was the acoustic
evidence and I believe that acoustic
evidence and I've talked to Don Thomas
and I've heard him speak on a number of
occasions and I urge you to go on the
internet and find Don Thomas's articles
because they're very persuasive about
the acoustic evidence naturally there's
been dissing formation attempting to
discredit the acoustic evidence what
else but I would really urge you read
Don Thomas because he's a scientist he
lives in Texas and he's done very good
work on the subject the writer states
the fact that sinister elements in the
CIA assassinated JFK is incontrovertible
there is evidence that the Mossad
collaborated would you please comment on
this I have no direct knowledge of it
okay
one last question have you received
threats against your life for your work
on this book I have not I have not been
reviewed I didn't get reviewed in the
New York Times The Washington Post
dismissed those people who say there is
a conspiracy the Baltimore Sun for which
I write gave me the worst review I've
ever gotten in my life
the New Orleans times-picayune headed
their review try and try again and so
I'm not expecting the Free Press to
revive itself any time soon before we
close a few things that I found
interesting as an ethical culture in
your book you write about
an organization called the central
mondiale commercial an Italian
organization that was a front for the
CIA and it turns out that the money used
to finance this organization was
supplied to a great extent by the
Seligmann banking family in Basel it
then says that it quotes my set my
parents were very interested in perm
index which is one of their
organizations Peter Sullivan search
wrote to Clay Shaw now for those of us
in ethical culture I'd like to quote a
paragraph written by Howard greatest one
of our formal leaders who says during
the winter of 1877 Joseph Seligman
announced that the Society for ethical
culture was to be organized Seligmann a
founder of the banking house of Sullivan
& Brothers was president of temple
Emanuel he was also the first chairman
of the group that organized the ethical
culture Society his death in 1880 came
as a severe blow to the fledgling
movement although his family remained
active throughout at this lifetime and
professor Edward ara Seligman one of
America's great economists succeeded his
father as president so we have a great
great-great grandchild of one of the
Seligmann family involved on the side of
the CIA justice pension one thing and
that is that clay Shah was a member of
the board of directors of that central
Mondale commercial on the other side
when Lee Harvey Oswald was seeking to
establish his pro Cuban credentials he
handed out leaflets on a street corner
and the leaflet that he handled handed
out was called the crime against Cuba
and that leaflet was written by Collis
Lamont one of the one of the major
figures in the American Humanist
Association